okay I have a Gaslight alert for you
today gas lighting is when you
manipulate someone into questioning
their own ability to understand the
world and the new gas light phrase of
the week from the Trump administration
is we are now testing more than South
Korea per capita and this is this is
going to be a painful one because it is
such weaponize this information but I do
think it's important to do this this is
the anatomy of disinformation for you to
understand very very clearly so we have
a corona virus pandemic the way we find
cases is by doing tests for the virus
right now they they've all been RNA
based tests an antigen test is now in
development and may soon be available
but so far you find cases by doing RNA
tests which require a number of
different elements in order to do the
test so far so good
South Korea and the United States find
their first respective cases of corona
virus within hours of each other we
often say January 20th I think one was
January 19 the other was the 20th with
the time difference it may have been
simultaneous it doesn't matter within
hours of each other South Korea and the
United States confirmed their first case
South Korea immediately develops a test
ramped up testing capacity tests
lots of people establishes fever clinics
to isolate people who test positive
contact traces exposed contacts of
infected people puts them in home
isolation and they do a fantastic job
with the virus all while not being
authoritarians remember South Korea is
ranked higher than the United States on
the new mock democracy index that was
January now Trump didn't do that we
didn't get much testing capacity until
the end of March which is essentially
two whole months during which South
Korea developed tested contact race etc
we started to ramp up testing at the end
of March if you looked at the numbers of
tests that we were doing in the first
part of March it was numbers like 600
tests in an entire day we got up to a
few thousand tests per day our testing
capacity was terrible at the time we
were about 50th or 55th
in the world per capita maybe even worse
I don't remember exactly now compare our
testing numbers in early March to South
Korea's positive test results by early
March South Korea was finding sometimes
800 positive cases in a day and there
was a period in early March where South
Korea was doing so much testing that
they were finding more cases than the
total number of tests we were doing
understand that comparison there were
days in early March we South Korea and
the US had our first confirmed case on
the same day days in March where we
would do X number of tests and South
Korea would have act that same X number
of positive tests because they were
doing so much more testing than us this
allowed South Korea to stop the spread
very very early now over time during
March April into May
our testing rate continued to really lag
we were testing 50th in the world you
know then 45th in the world per capita
then 41st currently our testing rate is
about 30,000 people per million that
puts us 40th worldwide in testing per
capita this is as a few hours ago
we are behind Singapore and Canada in
per capita testing but we are ahead of
the Czech Republic as examples and as we
were failing during March and April
reporters kept asking Trump and other
officials you keep saying we're doing a
lot of tests but what about per capita
because per capita were not it wasn't
clear whether Trump understood what per
capita meant and or was pretending not
to we didn't know the talking point was
we've done more tests than anyone in the
aggregate but of course per capita was
what was relevant at the time the new
talking point now is hey everybody's
talking about South Korea we now have
more per capita tests than South Korea
that is true and in fact our testing per
capita is now double that of South
Korea's but why is this gas lighting its
gas lighting because South Korea barely
has any cases there is no point now in
comparing us to South Korea because
South Korea barely has an outbreak at
this point in time
look again at South Korea's curve South
Korea hasn't had more than a hundred and
fifty cases in a day since March 11th
that's not a typo I want to say that
again South Korea has not had more than
150 cases since March 11th in the u.s.
we regularly have a thousand 1,500 2,000
2,500 deaths per day South Korea has not
had a day with more than a hundred and
fifty cases since March 11 that's two
months ago so the point is of course our
per-capita testing rate is now greater
than South Korea's they have nobody to
test because almost no one has the virus
we have a third of all the global cases
South Korea has 258 deaths total okay
total South Korea has 258 deaths the
Trump administration is now bragging
that our per capita testing rate is
higher than South Korea's but it's
actually an embarrassment it took months
for us to get our testing rate to match
that of a country that essentially
eliminated the outbreak two months ago
and we are still only 40th in testing
per capita there is no serious reason to
even mention South Korea anymore other
than to say that's what we should have
done they handled it correctly and we
didn't this is the new Trump is talking
point Trump is using it Kaleigh mcenany
used it yesterday during her press
briefing we need to be testing more
South Korea doesn't even have sick
people to test anymore there's no reason
to continue comparing ourselves to South
Korea at this point South Korea is an
instructive example for what we should
have done on January 20 that's almost
three months ago let's take a quick
break almost four months ago sorry let's
take a quick break and we'll be back
right after this